well we've got fire weather conditions
coming tomorrow so it's great news that
we've got a brand new fire station
opening today and it's on the valley's
east side to celebrate clark county fire
is inviting people
to come out and get a covid 19 vaccine
well bianca holmen is live on nellis and
charleston with
more on today's event this is great news
for the east valley bianca
yeah sheri this is great news for this
community i'm right here in front of the
brand new fire station
61 and not only will the station provide
much needed protection for this area but
there's an event today
that's going to bring vaccines to a part
of the valley that really needs it
according to the southern nevada health
district this zip code 89110 has the
most cases of coven
19 and all of nevada to celebrate the
grand opening of the fire station
officials will hold a pop-up vaccine
clinic starting at 1 this afternoon
they'll be administering the johnson
johnson vaccine which only requires one
shot
not two like the versions from pfizer
and moderna
the shot will be given on a first come
first serve basis
as far as this fire station construction
took about two years
it houses a fire engine portion of the
building and then a paramedic unit
it also has 12 sleeping quarters an
outdoor living space
kitchen gym entertainment room and this
new building actually replaces the old
fire house that was built at the same
location back in 1979
county commissioner william mccurdy will
be here for the opening ceremony along
with
the fire department and the vaccine
event today
is expected to have a great turnout and
of course there may be long lines and so
if those lines start to build early
they're going to give people wristbands
so that they can come back closer to
that one o'clock start time when they
cut the ribbon and have a guard out here
and things like that and welcome folks
to
this new fire station and again that
vaccine clinic that's much needed
here in the east part of the valley
reporting live from charleston and ellis
bianca holman
8 news now